you know your skin
reveals a lot about what's going on
internally
especially your liver if the liver is
good your skin's gonna look great if
it's not that good you're gonna look not
too good so in this video i'm gonna
cover all the different things that can
happen to your skin just from the liver
now i'm talking about having a fatty
liver i'm talking about having cirrhosis
and inflammation now the thing about the
liver it's a rugged organ it's about
three and a half pounds located on the
right side of your chest cavity and it
takes a beating and it can regenerate
though it can come back if you do the
right things so i'm going to give you
some really good things to eat to
preserve your liver but first we need to
identify um all the different
indications that there is a problem with
the liver using the skin so before you
see any problems on the blood test like
high levels of liver enzymes
things like that
you're not going to really know there's
a problem with the liver you might
notice some fatigue but you'll
definitely notice a change in your skin
okay now i'm going to cover 15 things
that can go wrong with the skin i'm not
going to
give you the big long medical name
because you don't really need to know
that but i will include the name on this
video so you can kind of see what i'm
describing but the best way to put
someone to sleep is just to give them a
lot of big words and i'm not going to do
that in this video all right number one
if your skin is yellow okay what's
happening is the red blood cell when it
breaks down turns into a certain
compound that then can turn your skin
yellow if this breakdown product is
backing up into the skin
and if it's a severe problem it can even
turn the skin slightly brownish but
typically yellow skin
yellow eyes is an indication that
there's some type of backup in the liver
it could also be in the gallbladder bile
ducts as well all right next symptom is
red palms okay if your palms are red it
could indicate that there's a definitely
a liver problem and also as a side note
if your palms are itchy or the bottom of
your foot is itchy that's another
indication that there could be a liver
problem as well or a gallbladder issue
all right a red nose okay let's say
the nose is red it's swollen
you see this a lot with alcoholics that
is an indication that there's probably
liver cirrhosis okay red cheeks they
call that rosacea that usually can be an
alteration in the microbiome in your gut
but it's also an indication that there's
a liver problem but there's other
indications too it could be an adrenal
issue but typically it's going to be a
combination of a liver problem or
you're just lacking friendly bacteria
all right next thing is loss of hair it
could be in your armpits or on your legs
if you're a guy that's a situation where
the liver is damaged and you don't have
that that buffer that regulates
excess estrogen in the body and so as
the estrogen increases
then you start losing that hair and the
skin becomes very very soft and even
shiny
you see this um
as a man ages when they get older
their
lower legs don't have any hair anymore
and it's very very super shiny that's
excess estrogen building up because the
liver is not buffering that amount of
estrogen all right next one is paper
money skin
what is that well if you ever looked at
crinkled uh old money it has a certain
texture to it a lot of times the skin
becomes that texture
when you have liver damage and you see
this on your cheeks
or the folds on your face and the skin
is very very thin and sometimes you'll
see it on the back of the hand too where
there's it's like paper thin skin it's a
loss of collagen which is part of the
normal aging process but you see it also
with liver damage all right spider veins
okay
specifically the ones that
have a little red spot with these little
veins coming out of that one red dot and
you'll see this on the abdomen you can
see it on the face you can see in other
parts of the body that again is excess
estrogen okay because the liver buffers
excess estrogen now we have the white
yellow growths around your eyelids that
is deposits of cholesterol and usually
the person has high level ldl and low
hdl and high triglycerides
that's a situation where they're doing
way too many carbs they usually have
insulin resistance they're usually
overweight because the cholesterol is
backing up into the tissues and out
through the eyes a simple remedy would
be to get off the carbs do intermittent
fasting and take purified bile salts all
right then we have purple flat little
bumps on your skin okay you might see
them in the lower extremity or
throughout the body that's indication
that there's a liver problem most likely
an excess amount of estrogen
sometimes you'll see that too after
pregnancy where you have this spike of
estrogen then we have purple little
spots which are kind of just not raised
they're not bumps but they're just
discoloration another symptom that
there's a liver issue now the liver
spots themselves where you have this
slightly
brown little spot or extra pigmentation
is not really coming from the liver it's
aging spots that is a lack of vitamin c
this is why
a real common remedy would be those
creams that you put on your skin that
always have a base of vitamin c this is
just an indication that you need more
vitamin c to make those go away but i
would recommend taking vitamin c getting
them from food and taking it
orally
and just realize that when you're on a
high carb diet or you have high levels
of sugar because you're diabetic that
can cause a vitamin c deficiency because
it blocks
vitamin c the chemistry of glucose is
very very similar to vitamin c so the
body will always pull in glucose before
vitamin c blocking it all right the
white scaling plaques as in dandruff now
that's usually a fungal growth and
selenium is one of the remedies that
they use for this fungus and a really
good remedy would be to take
some
olive oil
with oregano oil and kind of combine
that i'll put a link down below of how
to do it but you just rub it into the
scalp and it'll get rid of dandruff but
realize that the real problem with
dandruff is more internally and it's
usually a problem with your
microbes in your gut slash a liver issue
there's also topical probiotics that you
can put on your scalp
i will be doing some videos on that as
well then we have
other things like the crusty red nodules
that can occur on your skin
so as you can see a lot of skin problems
are connected or associated with liver
and then there's a condition called the
cities where you have this fluid-filled
sac in your gut
you usually see
the guy on the beach in the speedo with
this huge belly but he has his legs are
like stick thin his arms are thin and he
has stretch marks on the abdomen that's
coming from a very severe cirrhosis of
the liver and it's called the cytes and
you get these stretch marks but not all
stretch marks are liver but certain
stretch marks can be if it's coming from
ascites all right a flattened face where
you're losing fat on the face
that can happen with certain liver
issues because you're not able to
produce the growth hormone that works
through the liver anymore and you're
losing certain amounts of protein that
the skin just kind of falls flat
on your face and then maybe i should
tell you the name of that it's called
facial
lipodystrophy all right now for the good
news okay
there are foods that you can start
eating that can improve the liver and
you can help to bring the liver back uh
one of the best foods that you can
possibly eat for the liver is radishes
honestly i don't like radishes my wife
does i don't like them but i will eat
them on a salad but radishes are amazing
for the liver they're part of the
cruciferous family they're very bitter
but they have properties to help reverse
a fatty liver they trigger certain types
of enzymes that help to face one phase
two detoxification to get rid of poisons
they increase the bile production of the
liver radishes hands down are probably
one of the best vegetables for the liver
then we have lemons i just did a video
on this you blend the whole lemon very
very bitter anything bitter is good for
the liver if you haven't seen that video
i'll put a link down below but you can
blend it with water with little stevia
man that's really good for a fatty liver
and then we have apple cider vinegar
which supports
your blood sugars which actually makes
insulin more sensitive and that alone is
going to reduce the fat on your liver
then arugula which is one of my favorite
cruciferous vegetables very bitter very
good for the liver it's way better than
regular lettuce so you might want to use
that in your salads instead of other
types of vegetables but anything leafy
green is going to be awesome for the
liver and of course out of all the
vegetables the cruciferous vegetables
are a superior vegetable for the liver
then we have garlic
is really good for the liver i mean i've
done so many videos on that and then we
have sea kelp sea kelp helps regulate
excess amount of estrogen okay so that's
another really good thing to add to the
mix mustard any type of mustard is
really good for the liver
in regular yellow mustard you have
turmeric you have mustard seed you have
apple cider vinegar paprika really good
for the liver dandelion greens very
bitter
awesome for a fatty liver
and then egg yolks which is loaded with
lecithin which is the antidote to
cholesterol
eggs are very awesome for a fatty liver
now if you haven't seen my video on how
you can identify liver problems through
your foot
check this out it's right here
you